before we go here's one thing you can do
today to live a happier healthier and
more productive life it's part of our
partnership with Gretchen Rubin and her
award-winning podcast happier
research shows that how you start your
morning sets the tone for your entire
day so if you're frazzled now it may be
a hard feeling to shake off New York
Times bestselling author Gretchen Rubin
is here with how to create a calmer
morning routine Gretchen good morning
good morning
we should stipulate we're talking about
people with normal morning hours or even
three so what's the first step in
creating a better morning routine well
we all know it but the challenge is
doing it which is get ready the night
before get your papers together and get
your gym clothes together if you're
taking lunch and snacks if there's
errands you need to do get that ready
the night before what's this thing
called the slow morning so this is a
thing we're PK Sunday bring people who
can do it with their schedule really aim
to have solitude reflection moving
slowly silently to start their morning
right just to kick off the day without
feeling frazzled and rackety is it
really possible to get a calm morning if
you have children under the age of ten
in the house okay it's hard but one to
get them ready the night before get
their clothes ready so you're not
searching for the socks or the uniform
one thing don't use an alarm clock use
an alarm clock not your voice to wake
them up because you don't want to be
associated with that
give them warnings you know 15 minutes
and so to help them pace themselves as
they go through I'd like one of those -
yeah because you sort of get you get off
track I don't need someone to remind you
how does making your bed set the tone
this is so funny so many people say that
this is the way they start their day
right by making their bed it's simple
when you're in control of your
surroundings you feel in control of
yourself no I always like that because
then when you come home everything looks
very nice that's right it doesn't
usually work in my house but we try yeah
well I mean my spouse is still in bed I
leave the house I don't I can't really
make it over her
when she tries she does it get hot
though I make my bed in a hotel room on
the morning I check out I love making
them how do you how do you avoid the
sense that you're always rushing in the
morning one thing is always keep the
important things in the same place the
keys the charger of the wallet and
another thing is and this is not what
everybody would want to do sometimes
starting off 15 minutes earlier you're
marching all right Gretchen Rubin thank
you so much that does it for us just
we'll see you tomorrow right here on CBS
this morning thanks for watching
everybody